what's going on everybody today I'm
going to show you how to calculate a
Hyundai or kia password using the xhorse
key tool
Max for this to work you'll need the key
tool Max itself either a working key or
a key blank if it's all keys lost and
internet
connection what we're going to do is on
the main menu for the key tool we're
going to select transponder
clone we're going to hit the Clone
button where we're going to see a couple
options
here now you're going to have to do your
research and verify that you have the
right transponder type because your
instructions are going to
vary this is
id46 so we're going to select id46
online calculation and hit start
clone from here we see a couple more
options including Kia Hyundai
password where it's now asking us to put
our key into the antenna the key
tool now you will need internet for this
part to work and it will take a bit of
time okay so from here we do have a
couple more
options we'll do original key clone
recommended
now it's asking us for data acquisition
for the key tool antenna to go up to it
looks like an
ignition this is a push to start vehicle
where we do not have an actual ignition
so here's what we're going to be doing
you have a push to start button right
here that's not going to be doing
anything this is a 2010 kou and you'll
notice that it has a slot right
here this is where our key is going to
go so I'm going to position the key
tool to be in range of that slot and I
should just have to take the
key and put it in
there so the key has now been
inserted we can pull the key out and our
key tool is asking us to place the key
back into the antenna ring so let's go
ahead and do that and see what it
does so now it's calculating the data
essentially since this key is programmed
to the
car you put it into the emergency start
slot and it's going to acquire the
password through that connection of the
key and the key
slot now this works on all keys lost as
well and there we have
it smart key password 820 358 with this
password we could add keys do all keys
lost and uh get that programmed I hope
this helps thank you